just real quick following up something
you said you just joked about there not
being a career do you feel like that
every time one job ends because you are
essentially it's like a snow globe
you're shaking it up you know yeah
absolutely
oh my god yeah I remember what had
happened but I was talking with someone
who had the kind of typical
oh you're working in TV and film oh my
god and I'm thinking you know man
I'm on set the lights are on the cameras
going the mics hot the crews standing
around they're setting up the shot
changing you know a lens relighting
something whatever it is there's a
little bit of a break I've got my cell
phone out and I'm answering emails I'm
sending off texts looking for work
returning phone calls if I've got a
second without interrupting everybody
else and then put it away and go right
back into it you know hustling right on
the set in the trailer in the makeup
chair right it never ends so yeah I
always feel like that I think every
actor can I've never heard an actor not
saying that unless I mean you're lucky
enough you get you know your own show or
you have a proper you know movie career
where keeps on coming but even then it's
it's an up and down and you just never
know you know that being said why do you
think people fail at it then fail at
having consistent acting work it's a big
question there are a number of factors
at play but if I kind of pull out and
take the meta view of it or like the
30,000 foot view like if you're in a
plane 35,000 foot whatever it may be
I think people probably aren't clear on
what they want and I also think that
most people don't investigate themselves
and know themselves well enough and
don't
manage their emotional states better
because you know ultimately everything's
a psychological game ultimately right
because you know we're all out there and
everybody here is talented like
everyone's talented ridiculously
talented the competition level is high
right and it was like that I laid
college sports and it was like that got
to I'm gonna forget when I got to
college you know I played football like
oh my god these guys were all so good
Wow
right and so then it becomes a mental
game right a psychological game managing
your emotions staying focused you know
making sure you're not giving some kind
of crazy meaning to something that
happened that doesn't help you doesn't
serve you and push you down the field or
down the path towards whatever it is you
want being clear your goal and that you
notice when you start to you know go off
course maybe you have crazy emotional
reaction to something or or it gives you
a bad feeling or whatever right so those
those things are important and I think
that's a long-winded answer but that's
why more people aren't as successful as
they could be and work more often
generally speaking that's like that is a
big question but generally speaking I
would say we start there you know it
just looked at a book just recently and
it was called um I won't say who the
person was cuz then I want to sort of
break their anonymity even though
there's a book out about them but they
basically said it was the female
so-and-so who was basically they used
the male version trying to say that this
person could have become that if they
could hadn't managed their emotions
different things drinking was another
one I said and so they showed this
person's rise from sort of obscurity and
was like the poor relation and to their
subsequent downfall and just how sad it
was but I thought that was interesting
because it could be a metaphor for a lot
of people and it's it is managing
because a crazy things can happen in LA
absolutely and and I like what you said
sort of like I'm not sure if you said
don't not overreacting or managing that
and there's a little skill it is a skill
and you know it's one that you you have
to work at to develop because it's not
we're taught you know like that would be
a really really like critical
foundational course that should be in
the educational system if you're asking
me I don't know that you are but you
know that's a life skill that's
invaluable and you know I I I've got my
my my my nerdiness and one of the things
as I always like to study people who
have been you know massively successful
or influential in an across a broad
spectrum of disciplines and industries
and and there's what let me ask you what
do you think would be the common the
common denominator with the most
successful people and I know that's what
a successful mean so let's just say
financially you know spiritually
emotionally psychologically physically
the most successful people what would
you think is the most common trait that
they have from what I've seen I think
people that are just obsessed with
something it doesn't even mean that
they're good people or that you know and
anywhere on the spectrum of sort of
intentions but I think being so obsessed
with whatever they are into whether it's
acting whether it's stock trading
whether it's real estate whether it's
painting whether it's meditation I've
seen people that just had this laser
focus with something and they're
obsessed with the immigrants their life
the seven days a week that is a very
common answer and that certainly excuse
me that's certainly necessary you know
the the seminal book that Napoleon Hill
wrote Think and Grow Rich you have to
have that burning desire right white-hot
burning desire which in today's world's
like I'm obsessed
everybody says obsessed it's not
necessarily the best word to use but
it's the word of the day so yes that's
it but but the the the trait that people
see that's that's kind of a given is
self compassion so sort of
self-awareness or or of compassion
compassion can you can you take me
through that what that would be sure
self empathy so not beating up on
oneself there you go interesting I do
not have guessed that yeah well
you know what I but they all do from
just reading and studying different
people male/female different industries
different disciplines different races
origins you're gonna make mistakes you
are going to write so since we're
talking about acting and within this
film courage and writing there's a lot
of writers that watch this and I mean
what writer do you know that doesn't
beat themself up what actor do you know
that doesn't beat themself up right
right like there's that neurosis that's
always like sitting on your shoulder
here you know that anxieties over here
and just like oh my god were they
thinking about me like give yourself a
break relax all right because reality is
most everyone not even thinking about
you that's true yeah they're thinking
about themselves
pS they're having the same conversation
here you are and they're thinking you're
thinking that about them right right
we're all human beings all right
give yourself a break you're doing the
best you can do with what you have at
that time and if you are obsessed as we
say or you have that burning desire
whatever it may be then just trust that
you're gonna make mistakes but that's
how you learn mistakes are a great thing
I never used to think that way if I
sound I wonder how that's sounds
probably crazy to say that but it's the
truth mistakes mistakes are a blessing
man number one it means you're still
alive you got problems you're still
alive there's an old story some guy was
taking a guy and his son are driving
through town and kids talking about
problems problems problems you know Dan
I just wish I have any problems they
drive by the graveyard he goes you don't
know one place they don't have problems
he points to the graveyard
those problems are good they're assign a
life son so yeah yeah it's the truth
though right you're gonna make mistakes
that's how you learn man that's how you
learn pain is the greatest teacher there
is and everyone runs from it to their
detriment myself included right I find
that very interesting so instead of
let's suppose you bomb an audition or
someone tells you you're horrible
whatever
I've never done that so I don't know
that I can instead of sort of reenacting
like Nicolas Cage's character in leaving
Las Vegas yeah be more like you know
what I'm gonna go for a hike I'm gonna
take care of myself that's not as it's
not a sexy and glamorous though you know
I think a lot of us I know Julia Cameron
said tortured artists get way more
attention and Pat's on the back then
people that are in it you know so I'm I
wonder if we kind of fall into this
wanting to almost be a tortured artist
because it gets more attention and
people like you more then if
everything's great I hate this person
yeah man it's kind of a yeah it happens
it can definitely happen right but it's
kind of a [ __ ] narrative it really
is tell me and well you know like you
just said it's not as sexy and glamorous
and it's ironic because who's sexy who
sexified and glamorized it that's sure
right mm-hmm and so they you know the
same thing with with painters you know
van Gogh took his ear off right nobody
knew who he was thought he was a
bachelor crazy and now he's worshipped
in the door but he's not around for it
anymore
right so yeah I don't know you know I
mean it happens I understand I don't
want to poopoo it it's tough I've rested
with it I still do
you know I'm not immune to it by any
stretch of imagination but yeah man you
got to give yourself a break you got to
do the best you can and I have I can't
believe I still work oh I look back at
some of my old work it's just I just you
know you cringe
I cringe like oh my god oh my god right
the imposter syndrome they say they're
gonna figure out one of these days are
gonna figure out you have no idea what
you're doing
everyone feels that way I've had the
good fortune of knowing dining with
being friendly with you know world
leaders and and and senators and federal
judges and civil rights leaders and and
they all have this similar everyone
across the board everyone
everyone feels like that you know and I
think it would be more helpful if we all
would hear that more often and realize
that more often and it's like okay man
yeah I feel like a fraud you know what I
you know I I feel yeah I think we can
probably see that my eye is twitching or
they can probably they can probably my
stomach gurgling or I should have had
that garlic last night or whatever it
may be and you just say f it I'm gonna
go ahead and do it anyway
you